it's uh drew's news is celebrating
hispanic heritage month
and we are all thrilled to celebrate it
with our next guest
she's a latina makeup artist turned
c-e-o
her incredible success comes from this
one
tiny but mighty invention we actually
talked about her with cristela alonso
on the show uh this is the beauty
blender
if you didn't already know and it's
revolutionized the beauty industry and
become a
multi-million dollar brand with over
50 million sold so instead of just
talking about her
we get to talk to her here she is it's
ria
and silva
[Applause]
i mean we really we were talking about
you on this show and now we actually get
to talk to you that's so exciting
i mean i work in the beauty world
as i have for basically like the last 15
years i started with
covergirl as a co-creative director and
then i started
a brand called flower beauty about a
decade ago
there's i don't think there's much to
turn to
like the beauty blender that is such
a outlier in importance how did you
come up with this oh my god well first
of all thank you so much for that it's
such
an honor to be here with you drew i'm
such a fan and i love flower beauty by
the way
um yeah so basically i'm a makeup artist
right i worked in film and television
for over 30 years
and i got this job i
was department heading this experimental
show called girlfriends and i say
experimental because it was
the first show being shot and broadcast
in high definition
and so makeups look different and we
needed to find a way
uh to have these four girls these
beautiful four girls on
uh girlfriends look natural and not look
like they were wearing a lot of makeup
so
they hired me long story short i was an
airbrusher a beauty airbrusher and
uh but that's not very practical to be
on set with an airbrusher so
beautyblender was the invention that i
came up with that allowed me to make
really beautiful natural makeups but
still do makeup
and still you know be corrective and do
all the things that makeup does
and basically that's how it happened and
i never thought it would be this like
huge global brand i never thought that
i would be selling to consumers i
thought that other makeup artists would
be the only one
the only ones that really could
appreciate this tool but you know here i
stand on the drew barrymore show right
now talking to you about beautyblender
first of all you also i believe you saw
this
as a because when you work in beauty you
get a lot of lab samples and you'll fall
in love with the
thing and they're like oh no no no you
can't have that um
or that stock or you know the packaging
and the coloring they're like no no that
said rendering
you saw this from the lab and this was
the color right and you were like
that's it is that true oh my god yeah so
you're right so they send you all these
samples right of what you're trying to
make
tons of samples yeah and every time you
get a sample they say don't look at this
don't look at that
exactly so when i got this one box and
it had been
like a couple years like i was really
perfecting it because this material is
unlike anything else
and so we were really perfecting the
material so when i got this box
they were like don't look at the don't
look at the color just look at the
material because this material we think
we nailed it this is it
so i opened the box up and i saw this
note saying don't look at the color
so of course i was like totally curious
i had no idea what it was going to be
and it was like all of this pink right
here and i was like
oh my god this is the perfect color
because i'm revolutionizing this tool
that i think
everybody needs to have and i need
people to see it from across the room
so when i went back to them and i said
oh i love the sample the material was
amazing it was perfect
and they said what about the color i was
like i love the color and they were like
you can't do that color
yes yes i can and your chair is made of
beauty blenders i believe
it's our beauty blender throne oh my god
drew this is a funny story so
um i did a competition in these stores
that sell beauty blender and whoever
sold the most beauty blenders would get
this beauty blender thrown
and so there were two people that won
and we made these two chairs and we sent
it to them and they sent the chairs back
because they couldn't fit in their
apartments
it was in new york city and they
couldn't fit them in so i said send them
to me so they're in my office now
well i just have the urge to motorboat
it and get my face right in the beauty
blenders
and i am telling you you
have truly made your mark in the world
and you are such an inspiration
and i know that working on you know
black skin tones and brown skin tones
and as a latina
you have really brought to the forefront
uh your inclusivity and your mission
as well as becoming this pioneer and ceo
that
everybody can innovate their beauty
routine with
and so we celebrate you here on this
[Music]
show
you